[Musique]
durant les jeux mais c'est
bernard avait une vie complexe
faisait juste confiance aux débiles et
manteau puis aux décès de ghislaine
lanctôt le dr ghislaine lanctôt qui
s'est fait connaître avec la publication
de son best-seller très controversé la
mafia médicale se retrouve aujourd'hui
devant le comité de discipline du
collège des médecins restent y en a qui
croient encore que le sida est
contagieux c'est la plus grande
imposture du siècle sydor supercherie
scientifique et arnold humanitaire et a
vraiment été manipulé il ya eu lavage de
cerveau complètement il y en est mort
c'était sa croyance
jusqu à aujourd hui
[Musique]
tous
où
c'est quoi la dernière chose que tu
aurais ministre
juste que je les remets
[Musique]
expo
mais qu'est ce qui est arrivé
mon frère c'était quelqu'un d'être très
intense la vie avec lui c'est si jamais
plate
qu'est ce que tu fous aujourd'hui
[Musique]
faire du bien et mes sauts rendre les
gens heureux
j'ai convaincu les gens un par un
[Musique]
en 2009 le chanteur bernard lachance
quito ce sommet de la gloire voici
bernard lachance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
méconnu mais brûlant d'ambition il loue
lui même le chicago streller et le
centre bell et réussi à les remplir se
méritant une attention médiatique
internationale
[Musique]
cunti porté sur quelque chose là y aller
jusqu'au bout c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma relation avec bernard lachance
remonte
très loin a fait on se connaît depuis le
primaire je croirais 2éme année
troisième année
bernard adhérer à toutes les théories du
complot possible et imaginable sauf
peut-être
que la terre est contrôlé par des
extraterrestres donc en mai 2007 bernard
m'a contacté me dis je de voirie l'homme
et manon j'étais pas au courant qu'ils
ont le vih mais que vih est pas liée au
sida puis qu'à cause de ça il prend plus
ses pilules m'explique que c'est
quelqu'un qui lui dit que tout ça
c'était pas vrai
passé des centaines d'heures à
m'informer sur ce que j'appelle
maintenant l'imposture du vih des galsi
dont je me bouffait plus jamais ce
poison qui a probablement affecter mon
système immunitaire l'anpif à l'insulté
a menti à ses petits soins des médecins
en born pyramide il y en avait pas de
ligne à chézy il le pot prix à créer
quelque chose en lui qui a fait que vous
voulu que ce soit pas vrai il cherchait
pour valider ses idées de faux vih
quelqu'un qui a vraiment confiance
ghislaine manteau est une médecins des
chu
à l'audition de la cause du dr ghislaine
lanctôt devant le comité de discipline
du collège des médecins du québec il a
été question de ses affirmations sur le
sida et selon un témoin expert en
immunologie les affirmations du dr
ghislaine lanctôt menace la santé
publique en 1994 j'étais à l'emploi du
collège des médecins comme syndic
adjoint ont fait des enquêtes sur des
actions dérogatoires aux normes établies
dans le code de déontologie de terre
l'entouré publier ou me livre qui
s'appelait la mafia médicale dans lequel
elle soutenait des propos qui étaient
contraires ou données de la science
médicale dans son livre la mafia
médicale le dr ghislaine lanctôt en plus
de dénoncer la vaccination par du sida
comme étant une grande conspiration
contre l'humanité madame lanctôt à
l'époque qu'avec un titre de médecin en
décembre 1994 j'ai déposé une plainte
devant le comité disputé à ce moment
alors j'ai été chargée de l'enquêté
alors un certain charisme
lanto faut que je le connaisse elle
avait deux de ses adeptes dans la salle
bien mais muet durant les audiences du
comité de discipline une manifestation
devant le collège des médecins avec des
parents leurs enfants
des propos que c'était que le cancer du
sein souffre d'une maladie de la pensée
et quand vous vieillissez seulement par
une pensée positive je trouve ça
dangereux pour la protection du public
de manière à entraîner des gens à spa
bon donner des traitements
en mai
1997 ils l'ont coupe connu le coupable
sur tous les chefs et nous on ne
demandait une radiation permanente de dr
ghislaine lanctôt vient d'être radié à
vie du collège des médecins ne peut pas
utiliser le titre de docteur lente ou
faut qu'elle se fasse à sa prime adam
lang tout moi c'était la première et la
seule fois que j'ai jamais demandé une
révocation pure c'est très très très
rare
qui joue
[Musique]
au système medicare
au système politique
au système légal
aux systèmes de médias
le lactose depuis les années 90 à
l'approbation de la différence vidéo de
santé alternative et je vous propose la
vie et l'immortalité suivant lecture
spirituelle du monde qui est en
confrontation avec la médecine
traditionnelle aux scientifiques vous
pouvez pas attraper le vih donc c'est
pas contagieux donc les souvent cité
comme autorité dans le milieu
complotistes
depuis la sortie de la mafia médicale
il y a près de 30 ans ghislaine lanctôt
multiplie les conférences et les
ateliers
je me réjouis elle demande maintenant à
se rappeler 10 guy une abréviation de
son prénom avec une combinaison des mots
dieux et déesses elle prêche la
souveraineté de soi et l'abandon de
toutes les institutions pour internet on
trouve pas juste des vérités et aussi
beaucoup de mensonges pluie bernard ça
fait son affaire parce que y'a toujours
en
d'être séropositif
[Applaudissements]
malgré tout les avancements qu'on a fait
dans la lutte au sida la stigmatisation
est là donc les gens vivent beaucoup
leur isolement donc c'est très lourd à
porter
la radicalisation c'est un processus par
lesquels quelqu'un adhèrent à des idées
extrémistes
c'est souvent le sentiment d'être
marginalisé d'être laissés pour compte
pas été entendu la médecine alternative
comme
toute forme d'idéologie peut conduire à
la radicalisation
en 15 24 mai 2017 bernard écrit
quelqu'un ne pourrais tu me donner le
email à dr ghislaine manteau ou lui
transmettre ceux ci bonjour madame
lanctôt j'aimerais de tout cas comme une
quinzaine ou pour une entrevue je suis
avec vous
ça c'est une de leurs premières
conversations
septembre 2017 mais guy je suis confus
maintenant je croyais que l'escroquerie
du sida étaient des fautes est si je
comprends l'article la maladie a été
créé et on me l'a injecté avec un vaccin
d'hépatite b effectivement je me suis
fait avoir mais j'ai besoin de la
médication qui a la réponse tu as toutes
ces informations en main bon voyage et
dort tranquille
c'est pouvant table le suggère dans le
fond de prendre sa propre décision puis
de dire
voilà tout et tout et leur et
mais lui envoie des articles à lui
envoie les articles envoyés des messages
twitter c'est sur la réalité c'est ton
ego est tension qui t'empêche de te
voilà
c'est comme ça qu'ils vous manipule fait
bois a changé et je l'attends qui va pas
bien il y avait des produits naturels
partout dans la maison il disait que
c'était pour nettoyer les vitres des
trithérapies qui avait pris qu'il y
avait un toxique et son corps il ya un
de ses amis médecin qui exhument vers
nantes est en train de mourir
la chasse
[Musique]
mais rarement montrées
il m'a parlé de la vidéo avec les images
de son corps squelettique
j'ai comme saisi que
la toute la souffrance qu'ils véhiculent
quand on a regardé cette vidéo le
moi j'ai vu dans le visage de bernard
qui s'était rendu compte que c'était
fait avoir
[Musique]
la dernière chose que ghislaine lanctôt
a fait pour bernos et qu'elle lui a
envoyé une infirmière est la veille de
sa mort pour injecter un soluté dans son
corps elle sait que ça servait à rien
mais c'est la suite pour l'hydrater ben
salah vahid rater
jusqu'à sa mort
d'alors est mort le 11 mai 2021
bernard est décédé d'une 7,6 me liés au
sida j'ai lu n'a pas pu connaître je lis
ça est
vraiment ça m'affecter le lien très fort
dans nos relations avec nos pc et moi
j'ai lu ça avec beaucoup de tristesse
je m'excuse
je dirais que les le première personne
responsable de cendres s'est lui-même
parce qu'il a choisi de l'assumer c'est
elle qui est qui inquiète bien confiance
je peux vous dire que si bernard avril
crie sa trithérapie
il fera encore vivants c'est clair
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quant à elle atteint tout risquer pour
écrire quoi la masse
les crises servent souvent de
mobilisation pour les mouvements
extrémistes figure là sont des gens qui
ont exploité la crise actuelle pour
faire avancer les idées qu'ils avaient
depuis souvent assez longtemps que j'ai
vu c'est tout ça c'est du bonbon des
microbes et virus sur les aides
c'est une peur de me l'apprendre la
pandémie a donné un second souffle aux
propos de ghislaine lanctôt ses théories
sur les vaccins et les virus résonne
chez certaines personnes qui s'imaginent
un scénario semblable avec l'aco vide
c'est dans ce contexte que bernard
lachance a trouvé un nouveau public que
le vih cause le sida est un mythe trajet
commencé à étudier la fraude vih je
pensais voir ça je pensais me dérobe qui
est quelques uns c'est des faux positifs
dont moi de batna c'est tout et elle me
disait que bon l'idée de des charmants
elop enfin de l'argent sur le dos des
jungles même qui donne des maladies
voulu aux gens pour pouvoir leur donner
des médicaments cités
le fait que tout ce qui est virus
maladie
cc c'est des mensonges il faisait juste
confiance aux déguisements tôt il n'y
avait pas moyen de faire changer d'idée
bernard lachance n'est pas le seul à
avoir été séduit par la doctrine de
ghislaine lanctôt nous avons rencontré
un homme qui dit que l'ancien médecin a
également bouleversé sa famille il a
demandé l'anonymat afin de préserver les
liens avec ses proches
j'ai lui affirmé disent que je suis un
sur des choses selon l incidence
existant qui est celle messieurs mathieu
malade j'avais possible chez ma soeur
aînée qui elle était adoptée avant tout
si j'ai lu
je me retourne je
mets le dommage était déjà fait
selon notre témoin sa soeur aînée a
transmis les enseignements de ghislaine
lanctôt à leur soeur cadette cette
dernière suivi en psychiatrie au cessé
de prendre ses médicaments et symisa
renie tout traitement médical elle est
morte en 2002
une bâche à la pièce et puis de l'italie
a fait 207 wafa novelli il a eu envie de
la traiter près ledit man en un an ce
programme - quand même un point pur
ya pas qu un placement des pubs sont
maintenant au début parce que les
réfugiés d un soin du linge le sujet de
la chambre d'hôtes tout est faux tous
les systèmes sont en train de
s'effondrer parce qu'il s'en fout plein
empêcher une personne seule continuez à
désinformer la population en un peu
population à ce jeu pour mâcher de
populations vulnérables que moi se
défend jean thomas
l'immortel c'est quoi qu'il est lente
aux importants déjà été confrontés aux
dommages qui peuvent causer ces conseils
il ya plus de dix ans en quête vous
présenter l'histoire des soeurs
st-arnaud dont le père est décédé après
être entré dans leur but de l'ancien
médecin nous avons relancé and st-arnaud
pour recueillir ses impressions après la
mort de berlin
quand j'ai su que cet homme là est
décédé parce que va arrêter ses
traitements ça m'a ramené dans le site
bon c'était un homme très ancré dans la
réalité et commencé à suivre des
ateliers de biologie totale et biologie
totale ou la mutuelle de la mer il a
ancré l'ex médecin et madame guylaine
mentaux ils sont devenus quand même à
ses amis on va donner mon par développer
en france elles et ils l'auront refusé
les traitements décidé d'abord parlé au
médecin mon père qui disait
25 ans c'est très grave auparavent et où
des parents quand celles qui avaient pu
très bien que ce soit ni mon cancer de
la prostate mais ils ont refusé et sa
déjeuner cinq ans après la mort d'andré
st-arnaud enquête avec questioning
ghislaine lanctôt sur le rôle qu'elle
aurait eu dans cette affaire
interne aux quelque chose je crois
compagnie ingénieurs à québec
je ne
vois
dans la bibliothèque d'andré st-arnaud
la famille pourtant trouver des livres
de ghislaine lanctôt avec des dédicaces
personnalisées
j'ai besoin que c'est un os delhi qui a
perdu la vie c'est un choix mais
y adhérer à des choses
qui étaient à mes yeux extraits
je vais donc mettre fin à cette journée
et encore un grand merci à monique et
toute organisation
pour avoir fait ce rendez vous passez
maintenant on attend des traces et les
ateliers et tu sembles sera de l'elysée
[Applaudissements]
on a voulu savoir ce qui se disait lors
des ateliers de ghislaine lanctôt en
2021 enquête a donc réussi à s'y
infiltrer avec une caméra cachée
nous avons pu comparer notre expérience
à celle de vincent l'ami de bernard
lachance en avant 2019 je suis évité par
bernard a assisté à une conférence de
guy ghislaine lanctôt
mas guilhem il l'appelait
avait à peu près 150 personnes il ya des
objets etc sont en vente des livres je
me rappelle que son habit l'imam avait
fait sourciller un peu un vêtement unis
qui rappelait probablement les uniformes
derrière elle ce qu'elle appelle le
grand portrait de l'évolution de la
conscience humaine où le monde est
divisé entre des moutons blancs des
moutons noirs qui ensuite qui est la
bergerie se transforme et deviennent des
humains sous leurs ailes puis ultime
mains d
[Musique]
chemin
j'appelais
qu'au portugal
juin
dans l'univers de ghislaine lanctôt le
but ultime et l'actualisation de l'être
humain en une jument et les uns être
souverain qui se détache de toutes les
institutions et qui abandonne tous ses
rôles
moment donné il ya quelqu'un qui pose
une question qui dit même o'shea
diabétique est ce que ça veut dire que
vous me conseillez vraiment de cesser
prendre mon insuline je me rappelle pas
les mots exacts de la réponse de
ghislaine tout ce que j'ai compris c'est
qu'elle lui proposer de prendre cette
décision mais les médicaments ça marche
pauvre m c'est une déclinaison du fameux
faites vos recherches
cinq amis spécialiste du vih club tu vas
voir un
biologiste ou quelque chose souvent
guergis très sonore et qui capable de
rejoindre ces gens là avec un certain
discours scientifique et c'est cette
personne là que l'on va croire si on
veut croire on veut croire mais les
autres 50 mille autres stars pris vie
des gens de traitement qui aurait pu
contribuer à ce qu'ils soient encore en
vie c'est une responsabilité non moi je
ne serai pas de vivre qu'un sentiment
comme seulement de revoir la lenteur
dans les médias ça vous fait quoi je me
suis dit est-ce qu'on a tout fait sur
bordeaux rien ma première réaction c'est
un peu chaud mais après ça je me suis
dit non parce qu on lui a enlevé sa
crédibilité au moins en fait ceux auprès
d'un certain public
la pandémie en audience
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'auteur du lingotto lesquels
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une varices une
varice situe dans les années 70 et 80
ghislaine lanctôt se fait connaître à
travers l'amérique du nord pour son
expertise dans le traitement des varices
entrepreneurs elle fait sa place au sein
de l'élite québécoise si le dépôt était
médecin succès les jeunes y attendrez
pas autant de crédibilité je crois vous
avez co fondatrice du bottin des femmes
vous avez des cliniques franchise est un
peu partout j'ai commencé à ouvrir des
cliniques à différents endroits en inde
après je suis allé en ontario et puis
après j'ai dû écouter les américains
depuis le temps qu'ils nous vendent des
trucs on va les leurs avant elle a
laissé tomber une vie de millionnaire
[Musique]
ghislaine lanctôt commence l'écriture de
la mafia médicale au début des années 90
celle qui a fait fortune en médecine
conventionnelle change son fusil
d'épaulé pour faire la promotion d'idées
anti science et de propos extrêmes elle
réfère ses lecteurs ou livres qui l'ont
inspiré or plusieurs ont été écrits par
des antisémites notoires
en 1995 ghislaine lanctôt fait faillite
dans sa déposition elle témoigne que la
mafia médicale est une oeuvre
humanitaire qui dénonce l'industrie
musicale à profit on apprend qu avant la
publication de son livre elle aurait
tenté de vendre ces cliniques pour des
millions de dollars afin d'assurer sa
retraite mais au moment de sa faillite
ghislaine lanctôt prétend ne plus rien à
voir ni résidence ni droits d'auteur ni
clinique il ne lui resterait que 300
dollars en actifs
dans le jugement de la faillite la cour
tranche que madame lanto était la seule
responsable de son insolvabilité et
qu'elle avait fait preuve d'insouciance
on souligne également la disparition d'
actifs tangibles sans aucune explication
puis killen l'entourent cesse de payer
ses impôts
le procès de ghislaine lanctôt qui
refuse toujours de se produire ses
déclarations de revenus a été reportée
au 23 juin l'ex médecin de 66 ans qui
était emprisonné depuis mois d'avril a
été remise en liberté par mois je ne
réponds toujours n'identifient plus une
entité jeu
de mots en 2008 ghislaine lanctôt passe
deux mois en prison en lien avec cette
affaire j'ai alors prison aujourd'hui
enfin procès et puis de procès moi j'ai
jamais à lui que c'est vrai moi qu'il
appelle
les citoyens souverains prétendent que
chaque individu peut choisir de ne pas
être assujetti à tous les types d'impôts
ce songe à qui se voit rupture avec le
système judiciaire et prétendre
également que l'individu peut décider
qu'il n'est pas assujetti aux lois de
l'état
soixante
ans que j'entends des cons spyder on
nous reproche de faire de l'argent mais
on veut et on fait de l'argent oui mais
se fait de l'argent pour dimitri c'est
ça qui hypothèque
les horaires et les coûts des ateliers
de la lenteur sont pas nécessairement
disponibles sur son site web pour avoir
les détails précis faut vraiment faire
partie d'une liste d'expédition prostate
donc on ne réussi à l'obtenir c'est un
horaire d'environ quatre mois où on
trouve cinq ateliers qui varient ont
pris entre 120 à 600 dollars l'atelier
auquel on a assisté nous a coûté 300
dollars il y avait à peu près 30
participants donc on estime que cette
fin de semaine le glénan tôt fait
environ 9000 $ ce sans compter les
produits délais une livre qu'elle
vendait sur place
s'il
[Musique]
est en pleine pandémie l'offre
d'ateliers étaient dépassés par la
demande
je
bien évidemment quelqu'un qui prétend
vivre en dehors du système économique
mais qui par ailleurs
demande 300 $ pour participer à ces
conférences il ya quelque chose d'un peu
contradictoire ou incohérents l'a7 à
cette position si une personne
tire des revenus elle a l'obligation de
déclarer ses revenus l'a aidé à payer
l'impôt sur ces réunions ghislaine
lanctôt prétend toujours qu'elles ne
paient pas d'impôts et ce sans
conséquence à ses adeptes elle offre
même des conseils pour éviter le fisc si
on laisse des gens et on donne son nom
partout au deuil ne fût ce que beaucoup
d'informations sur ce court du vent si
je vais tout un espèce pas de l'effet
tend à encourager les gens non seulement
elle peut produire des déclarations de
revenus mais à faire du twr cours est
usée l'argent comptant tous assez
différentes façons au fort de faire la
fraude fiscale
nos recherches démontrent que ghislaine
lanctôt utilise plusieurs stratagèmes
financier inusité par exemple la maison
où elle résidait la propriété d'une
fiducie géré par une de ses principales
partenaires d'affaires une femme avec
qui elle habite
série body je suppose que je vais dans
la misère non je vais bien dans une
région qui ne veut pas que les faits
visés doivent payer de l'impôt
mais le fait on ignore qui sont les
véritables bénéficiaires du rsa permet à
ses bénéficiaires là de rester dans
l'ombre ça ne permet pas de ne pas payer
d'impôts
nous avons tenté de contacter ghislaine
lanctôt par courriel puis par téléphone
mais sans réponse
en dernier recours nous nous sommes
rendus à son adresse pour avoir sa
version des faits
ghislaine manteau crois que bernard été
assassiné par big pharma
empoisonné il savait que c'était
supportable pour les établissements big
pharma on va dire que c'est suspect la
manière dont il est mort
était une grande famille un toit mais
la théorie que bernard ripert ce n'est
pas big pharma parce qu'ils étaient
sains croisade pour la vérité ça me
semble assez
impossible ridicule quand bernard est
décédé le lendemain les téléphones sont
nés ici déjà qu'ils voulaient reprendre
leurs prix thérapie bernard a été
influencé comme une influence jazz et
patatras rencontre ou ou pas mais à
pousse les gens au suicide est mort
s'est pas transformé un jeu mais il est
là et moi
[Musique]
aucune accusation criminelle qui va être
fait quand ghislaine lanctôt déjà qu'ils
adhèrent à des théories qui sont
néfastes pour pour elle même désespérant
pour les proches
mais c'est des choix qui est que les
personnes en fait
[Musique]
fallu aux autres ce que coûtera le jeu
dangereux c'est contraire à la science
est ce que la peine imposée à ghislaine
lanctôt était assez sévère ça c'est la
peine la plus sévère que pouvait il ya
pas de peines plus sévères que ceux de
la révocation de permis la radiation
permanente et pas plus sévères que seul
est-ce qu'il devrait y avoir d'autres
peines possède qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse de plus qu'avant de
professionnels je ne sais pas on n'est
pas un tribunal criminel demandant si
c'est des actes criminels il faudra que
ce soit une enquête policière qui le
déterminer on a besoin d'être protégée
de des criminels parce qu'ils sont
criminels ces personnes ne les gourous
qui veulent nous empêcher de voir les
médecins c'est criminel de faire ça ou
ça devrait l'être ça devrait l'être ce
l'époque mais ça doit vraiment y voilà
[Musique]